Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question
de Hugo, qui me demande :
« Est-ce que les Innus
sont une société matriarcale ou patriarcale? »
Hugo, c'est une bonne question,
parce que c'est difficile
de pouvoir expliquer avec des mots
qui ne représentent pas vraiment
culturellement ce que notre culture est.
Souvent je vais préférer plutôt que
de dire « patriarcal » et « matriarcal »,
c'est-à-dire « qui est dominé par la mère ou le père »,
on va utiliser « patrilinéaire » ou « matrilinéaire ».
Et souvent la partie
qui va diriger le clan ou le groupe va souvent
être la responsabilité de ceux qui vont
être les premiers à soit chasser
ou à faire pousser le maïs, la courge
ou les haricots, comme on voit chez et les Mohawks.
Donc, chez les Innus, comme on est une société
de chasseurs-cueilleurs,
on va voir beaucoup plus « patrilinéaire »,
parce que c'est le chasseur qui va faire
la grosse chasse. Donc on va suivre
le chasseur. C'est lui qui va trouver la
viande et l'animal sacré qu'est le caribou,
qui va nous permettre justement d'aller
vers une survie beaucoup plus certaine.
Cependant, on va vraiment voir aussi
l'apport des femmes dans la petite
chasse, c'est-à-dire la chasse qui va se faire
autour du campement. La pêche, aussi,
on va toujours poser des filets. En attendant
que les hommes reviennent avec de gros
gibiers, les femmes vont faire
de la chasse de petit gibier. Donc tu peux
voir qu'on ne pouvait pas parler
d'un pouvoir supérieur sur l'un ou l'autre.
Il y avait une codépendance des hommes
et des femmes à tous les niveaux.
Comme les femmes du système matrilinéaire
allaient dépendre aussi des hommes,
les hommes allaient dépendre aussi
des femmes. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il ne faut pas
parler d'un pouvoir de dominance
d'un groupe sur l'autre. Mais je dois
avouer que c'est souvent très incompris
quand on parle même de féminisme
autochtone de voir à quel point cette
lutte de pouvoir entre les hommes
et les femmes n'était vraiment pas
culturellement à la base des communautés
autochtones. Donc chez les Innus,
on est patrilinéaire, mais je peux
te dire que la grand-mère>
a toujours le dernier mot.
Et ça, ça a été prouvé scientifiquement­.
Donc, j'espère que ça
a pu répondre à ta question Hugo.
N'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions n'hésitez pas à partager les
vidéos bonne semaine